i feel amazing the weather in new york
is getting warmer it really is it really
is and we got all this extra light from
daylight savings time starting and
spring starts on sunday
i love this time of year i feel exactly
the same it's got me feeling so good i
can think about it i feel exactly the
same
well
petals on flowers are nearly in bloom i
know that springtime is
coming soon
now that we're all starting daylight
savings time
i can hear crickets
banging all night
wait what
that chirping in cricket means shouty
you fine they're out bumping uglies
until the sun shines springtime is all
about bugs having sex
hey look
there's a bee getting totally wrecked
i'mma talk about insect antarcos
i'm talking about insect intercourse
some bang and then die with no remorse
i'm talking about insect intercourse
well we weren't thinking exactly the
same yes we were nope
yes oh we weren't we were not no we were
spring is about weather and going
outside and the creepy crawlies hitting
it right
did you know that flies can hit it from
behind
i can't look away
i don't think they mind
cause i'm gonna talk about insects and
tacos
i'm gonna talk about the insect
anti-cosmos buzz [ __ ]
[Music]
amber
springtime is about renewal it's about a
celebration of life and don't say
exactly bugs are crucial to our
ecosystem tarek bugs fertilize plants
they're part of the food chain and they
can even help break down waste
huh
i guess i never thought about it like
that derrick bugs having sex means more
bugs sure they can be annoying and gross
and they have their little skeletons on
the outside like nasty freaks but they
also do so many amazing things that are
helpful to us and the planet
did you think about it like that you
didn't
you're right
pop the champagne
play brian mcknight
because all the bugs are banging tonight
they're good for the globe and that's
just a fact hey look
that mosquito is blowing out backs
cause i'm gonna talk about the answer
[Music]
and tacos
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you